well just in case you're wondering if
the new Democratic Congress will fund a
wall along our southern border we have
an answer the incoming Speaker of the
House has cleared it up no chance says
Nancy Pelosi walls don't work she
explains and more than that they're
wrong morally wrong watch most of us
speaking for myself consider the wall
immoral ineffective as he also promised
Mexico would pay for it so even if they
did it's immoral still now if you're
familiar with how things work in
Washington you may be wondering when did
morality begin to play such a central
role in the legislative process and the
answer is the day that Nancy Pelosi got
ordained Pelosi is now an archbishop in
the Church of progressive sanctimony her
spiritual gift hectoring listen to her
preach what the President did was
unconstitutional and indeed in my view
immoral it is an immoral issue this is a
moral challenge immoral unconstitutional
and competent short-sighted in immoral
our moral responsibility we have a moral
responsibility to moral responsibility
to the next generation it's just a
reflection of the weak moral authority
weak moral authority that is not a
problem for Saint Nancy her moral
authority is absolute she is a good
person you unfortunately are not so pay
attention as she explains once again a
border wall is immoral well fine
far be it for us to question the command
of an archbishop we'll take her at her
word God hates walls but wait if walls
are immoral what about fences Obama seem
to like them the bill before us will
certainly do some good it will authorize
some badly needed funding for better
fences and better security along our
borders and that should help stem some
of the tide of illegal immigration in
this country better fences as Obama
that sounds immoral and what about
Israel's security wall it's big and real
and very effective Pelosi supported it
actually she voted for a resolute
defending that wall from UN condemnation
it's confusing must have been before her
conversion but now the walls are
definitely immoral a few obvious
theological questions arise
what about doors and locks how about
hedges or security systems or airport
airport checkpoints or anything else
it's specifically designed to keep some
people out what about the gate in front
of Pelosi's weekend house is st. Nancy
against all of that of course not
Republicans often say the left opposes
borders we've said that many times but
it's not quite true in their own lives
Democrats are all for exclusivity
they're not in a hurry to resettle
refugees on Martha's Vineyard for
example they just oppose America's
borders America is a sinful nation they
tell us we can only atone for those sins
by giving what we have to the entire
world so there's a lesson here for
Republicans the president got elected by
promising a border wall people wanted
that they voted for him president
pledged that in almost every speech he
gave I'm going to build a wall and it's
going to be a real wall a big wall a
strong wall nobody's coming through
unless it's legal no gonna be a real
wall not a toy wall like we have right
now
don't worry folks we're gonna be
building the wall
well Paul Ryan never wanted a wall
Pelosi has made it crystal clear that
Democrats will never build one they'd
rather have the country fall apart first
in fact they've already made that
decision America's middle class is dying
the border goes unsecured the next three
weeks are the final chance Republicans
will have in a long time to keep their
promise on the wall it wouldn't be easy
to do it but it wouldn't be impossible
there's precedent for it Democrats lost
the house in 2010 and in the short
window before the Republicans took back
the house in the lame duck period Barack
Obama got quite a few of his priorities
into law
Democrats repealed the military's ban on
gay service members affirmed a nuclear
treaty with Russia they even passed
Michelle Obama's school lunch bill so
Republicans could fund a wall before
turning back to the house they could
have done it at any point in the past
two years they just don't really want to
keep that in mind